how did your parents react timing honey
call them that you were engaged just
showed a thing sobbing both of them my
parents are crying my brothers got on
the phone we're texting him texting me
once we exchanged phone numbers they're
so excited yeah Jordan I do have to ask
you I'm sure you're being asked this all
morning long but even from the start you
and your family had been really private
about your family matters and all that
you guys didn't want to make it public
which is great so after last night Chris
Harrison of course spoke about it after
the photo which seemed a little
unexpected seems like he kind of threw
you for a loop but why is it so
important to kind of keep your family
matters private you and your family you
know completing our older brother Luke
you guys have really haven't spoken
about it so why do you guys should
choose to do that it's you know I think
anybody in our situation we do the same
Family Matters are sensitive and private
and of course I knew what I signed up
for I knew was a show that I was gonna
have to be honest and I knew I wanted to
be honest with her and share her
everything I could about my life but
we're just excited about this next
chapter and and getting up I met her
yeah I met her family in Thailand I
haven't really seen him since except on
FaceTime a few times so looking forward
to that looking forward to getting to
know them more and getting her back to
Chico another time and